foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America it's a free call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Dr John
deloney number one best-selling author
of the book own your past change your
future and host of the very popular Dr
John deloney show on Ramsay networks
podcast you should check it out uh if
you want to know about mental health and
relationships and just getting along
with other other humans it's a big deal
and hard to do sometimes because
sometimes those humans aren't that human
so there's sometimes those humans say
human wrong that's cool
you don't you you really didn't think I
did okay
yeah okay so just just making sure
you're on the track he has a new book
out that we just put into pre-sale and
it is breaking all Ramsay records in
pre-sale thank you America uh it is
actually going to be published and uh
shipped to you on October the 3rd but if
you buy it now and the book is called uh
building a non-anxious life
um if you buy if you go ahead and buy it
now it's only 20 bucks and we throw in
75 dollars worth of items in other words
it helps John me the marketing team if
we pre-sell these it helps with the
marketing process
um big time and so we're willing to
bribe you to pre-sell it and also on top
of that it's an awesome book so you will
get uh of course the ebook and the
audiobook and other things smoke fire
and freedom uh his latest talk will be
sent to you right now and all on this
subject of building a non-anxious life
in one of the most anxious
cultures in the history of the world
that's right yeah I'm excited to get
that out into people's hands I've been
doing the podcast circuit as we ramp up
and
um it's I think the book's more of a
felt need than even I thought it was
yeah yeah well we knew that that because
we you did the quick read which is the
equivalent of a chapter uh that we put
out called redefining anxieties 150 000
of those sold so we knew that uh a lot
of folks were concerned about this
subject
um there's six daily choices in the book
that you make in order to build an
unanxious life and you know it is
honestly you you really did find a way
to weave between the nerd world of
psychology and um and Grandma's Common
Sense yeah it's got a it's got a lot of
both in there but in a way that's
digestible it I just want to tell you
this happened the other day I was
speaking you and I were just talking off
air I was speaking to a University
faculty and um all the faculty come
together that's called pre-session
happens at every University and I was
meeting it with the faculty and I
finished the talk and it went very well
and at the end and then the president
stands up to go up and I sit down in my
seat and I'm all by myself and I feel
somebody tug on my shirt
and there's a man in the aisle he'd walk
down in front of everybody in this
theater we were in
and he's got a name tag on his shirt
he's one of the maintenance guys
and he grabs my head from the back of my
he puts his hand on the back of my head
and gets real close he can whisper in
while the president University's talking
addressing these faculty the esteemed
faculty
and he said this changed my life thank
you and I remember thinking and he said
I've been listening to show I've read
one of the other things and he and I
remember thinking I wrote this book for
you I wrote this book it took all this
nerd stuff that me and my nerd friends
have to somebody who doesn't read a lot
of books who just wants to be a better
dad and I got choked up sitting right
there I was doing everything I could
just not lose it because it was a brave
act for that guy to walk all the way
down into and to bless me in that way
but
that's exactly what I set out to do
which is not to run man the Hebrew into
the world those guys are brilliant and
those Peter T's in the world those guys
are brilliant I I can't write like that
those guys are smart and they have they
have that that area covered I want to
write a book that for people who don't
read a lot of books but are just sick
and tired of living this anxious
stressed burned out life and so um it's
resonating in a way that I didn't
anticipate it's pretty neat yeah I think
one of the reasons this show has worked
for 30 years is is that we realize that
people
actually need other people and one of
the six choices is you know choosing
friends choosing Community choosing
relationships and uh the lonelier you
are uh the more you set yourself up for
anxiety so one of the things is to start
choosing in that area right yeah I I
have just come to believe I don't
believe the human body can be well in
isolation I don't believe it can be okay
you can make a bunch of money you can
get six-pack abs you can
find somebody to marry you I don't think
your nervous system will rest and relax
until it knows I got somebody watching
the right flank and somebody watching
the Left Flank and somebody that's
that's there for me in the middle of the
night we're just not designed to do it
um and so I don't know I think you can
do all the meditation and you can do all
the Gratitude journaling you can do all
that stuff if your body knows you're
alone you are not going to be
um well or whole and you're going to
show up to work on Mondays wondering why
you're snapping at your kids wondering
why you just hollered at your husband
wondering why you're so mad at your boss
has nothing to do with any of that stuff
has to do with the body trying to get
your attention saying we can't do this
by ourselves you know being a Hermit is
a mental illness yes it's tough yeah it
either is caused by it or will cause it
it's it's in its recursive right it
works in and of itself and it just
Builds on itself yeah yeah if you go if
you if you're a little crazy so you go
off by yourself and you get even crazier
that's right and I'll be the first to
say uh if you're hearing me say that and
you'll you look around you say yeah I'm
41 I'm 36. I'm 58 and uh the idea of
quote unquote going to make a new friend
sounds about as much fun as
setting my my hair on fire just to watch
it burn I addressed that it's the worst
and we gotta go do it anyway and I think
back to our great my grandparents some
of your grandparents
um I think your grandparents got off the
ark but my girl they
um I mean it was everybody smoked
everybody smoked
and it's when everybody I think they
didn't feel good but everybody smoked
and it's when they came out and go hey
whoa
everybody this is killing it it's gonna
kill you you gotta stop and
um there were some grandparents that did
and some that didn't it was hard it was
just hard and it's hard to keep smoking
and live that life and it was hard to to
stop smoking after smoking for extra
years you had to choose which is a hard
path and um if you choose the one that's
going to give you longevity in life and
give your health back that's hard and If
You're Gonna Keep just plugging along
that's gonna be a hard path too making
friends is very similar yeah living
alone is going to kill you
so you're going to live a lonely life
that's hard or you're gonna do the scary
hard work and say hey man you want to go
I'm gonna go grab a drink you want to
come over and and have dinner it's the
mate the culture has forgotten how to
call up and say hey bring a dish grab
dinner tonight just be weird yeah
whatever you got left in fridge come on
over yeah half a bottle or whatever come
on over yeah yeah exactly I've forgotten
how to do it yeah and um when someone
does it it's like oh that was cool it's
an awesome thing part of me forgot that
I mean like when we were kids we used to
do that you know and yeah but it's uh
we're too plugged into where we're going
out to eat
uh we're too plugged into
um it's the instagramification clicking
a button yeah and crap showing up on the
front porch well I even uh I've been
working with somebody
um off air not on my show and one of the
assignments I gave him and his wife is
you have to have somebody over for the
next 30 days once a week and you have to
intentionally leave something out in the
living room
like a laundry basket or a like a trash
sack you can't over curate this this
house you've got to be you and you gotta
deal with that uh what are they gonna
think about me it doesn't matter they're
your friends like they brought over a
half a dish it's probably not even that
good if they
do care then they're not the right yeah
exactly Winston and Rachel came over
recently they didn't mention our the
cleanliness of our house at all we just
laughed a lot it was awesome Rachel
doesn't need to mention the cleanliness
of anything that is correct all right
just to be sure there just to be real
clear on that all right there we go this
is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you foreign
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hollow.com Ramsay
[Music]
good
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today Debbie
is in San Francisco on line five hi
Debbie welcome to the Ramsay show
maybe not
I think I messed it up
try again how about now Debbie you there
I am here there we go what's up how can
we help
well I just want to know if if there's
ever a time when it would make sense to
pay off home debt with
um traditional IRA my situation is that
um I re recently retired and before I
retired we were cruising along we have
oh on our house about 65 000 we had
everything paid off my husband's
self-employed and had a business credit
card that he would pay off every month
through through that and all of a sudden
we had a situation after I retired where
we had a series of unfortunate things
happen so now I'm sitting here and it's
like we owe 64 000 on the house we now
have a brand new car loan that I didn't
plan on buying for another year or two
and
um we're basically retired my husband's
still doing a little bit of side work
but how old are you
I'm 65. how much is in your retirement
we have 1.1 million dollars why did you
not just take out money and buy a car
I don't care no
money except your IRAs
well we had about forty thousand dollars
but now it's down to about five yeah you
have no money basically except your IRAs
get a million dollars in traditionals
yes way to go you're millionaires you're
amazing
the fact that it feels all trapped kept
it from feeling amazing but just let's
just take a minute here and go hey
Debbie's a millionaire
let's just stop and say that right well
thank you yeah it does the general man
is too because he took the ride with her
so there we go but yeah all right so
what do you own a stupid car
okay so we owe thirty two thousand okay
so you need a hundred grand so you're
gonna take out 150. ta-da okay so it's
my stupid tax right no you have to pay
taxes on it yeah
yeah you might as well pay some taxes
okay so I'm so
so yes yeah we the only time we tell
people not to cash out retirement at
your age to pay off debt is if they
don't have enough
like if you told me I have a 500 000
mortgage and I have six hundred thousand
in my retirement I'd be going uh that's
a hard one right you're not but you're
not looking at that you got 900 grand
left over when we finish talking right
and uh and then the other time we tell
people not to use retirement is if
they're not over 59.5 so they get
penalized
so you don't cash out your 401K when
you're 45 because the government takes
10 plus your tax rate and they kick your
butt so all you're going to get hit with
is the taxes that you have never yet
paid on this earning on these earnings
oh I'm going to sleep so much better
tonight okay yeah your debt for you're
debt free by the end of the week you got
a couple uh keystrokes on the computer
to do to get the money out and get over
there and then you're fine
um and it's it's and you've got
mandatory required minimum distributions
at 72 you know that right yes yeah that
weird very work very aware of that but I
just felt like I had screwed everything
up no you haven't screwed everything up
the only I mean the only thing you did
is you probably bought a I might go back
and revisit that car decision it sounds
like you guys absolutely panicked but uh
but yeah but either way
um you know uh you got the money you're
millionaires I mean you can make a forty
thousand dollar mistake when you have a
million you can't make a forty thousand
dollar mistake when you have forty
thousand it's kind of a problem so
um but you set yourself up and it's not
even a mistake because you actually own
the car and now we're just paying it off
the only big mistake was that so that
that's the process all right let's go to
uh Joel in Houston hi Joel welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Ramsey how you doing better than we
deserve how can Dr John and I help
cool well thank you so much for taking
me on
um but see I'm calling you today this is
because I'm very nervous um about the
new student loan payments resuming and
everything
um so I'm 24 years old you know I make
sixty thousand dollars a year and I am
soon to be married so I'm currently
engaged congratulations
thank you sir thank you appreciate it
um what do you do yeah so
um I am a so I'm working in logistics uh
Transportation Logistics you've got a
supply chain to Green you make 60 Grand
yes sir well that sucks you need to make
more than that you're probably worth 80.
I'm working towards it yet it took a
while to get to 60. no I'm telling you
dude the marketplace right now is about
80 for a newly graduated I mean you got
a four-year degree in supply chain
yes sir okay yeah you're underpaid I'll
just tell you you need to go look at
anyway what how much student loan debt
have you got
uh so I have about 30 000 on a car you
know it's thirty thousand Joel
and you make 60. okay how much is your
student loaned at
18K okay and and your fiancee what's she
do
uh she works for
um
a government facility it's such a
children's Assessment Center um you know
they need to take care of children what
she make
whatever
um she makes 19 an hour
and she has a four-year degree
yes criminal justice okay
uh the two of you are vastly underpaid
so we're going to work on your careers
for sure
um you bought a car you can't afford sir
the car is in cray-cray land
Nutty Nutty Thirty a sixty thousand
dollar car you make I mean you make 60
and you have a 30 000 car that doesn't
work so you don't have a student loan
problem you got a car problem
yeah
nervous laugh means you're going to keep
it what's that mean and listen dude I I
drove the streets of Houston that's
where I grew up in a 1988 Tercel easy
hatchback a thousand bucks you don't
need a forty thousand dollar car when
you're broke
that is true it was just an emergency I
had no no it's not a thirty thousand
dollar emergency no it wasn't the beer
just fell in my mouth officer no you
bought it
okay man uh nervous laughs aside the
number one mistake newly minted college
graduates make is they go buy a car they
can't afford so you're not dumb you just
did what most college graduates do you
went and bought a car you can't afford
and if you don't hear this loud and
clear it's going to hold you back
because if you didn't have a what 650
car payment making sixty thousand you
wouldn't be calling me about the student
loan debt
so if I woke up in your shoes if you
were my son and you call me my nephew
and you called me and you said I'm
getting ready to get married Papa Dave
uh what should I do to get ready to have
a great life with this woman I'm in love
with I would say work on your career
you're underpaid you're worth more than
you think you're worth in the
marketplace today you're a stud supply
chain is an excellent degree field way
to go good choice and you bought a car
that indicates you were doing drugs so
stop doing this stop stop stop get rid
this would be Papa Dave talking to my
nephew be going you're out of control
dude you got to sell it so the best
thing you can do for the future Joel and
the future Joel's wife is to get rid of
this car and get you a beater and get
rid of student loans as fast as you can
by living on beans and rice rice and
beans and work on your career choice and
she needs to work on hers you go get a
four-year degree to make 19 you can make
19 at Target if you didn't even get out
of high school so
um that that's just ridiculous she again
you both have of accepted positions and
you've somehow Justified or rationalized
it that you're you're both worth more
than you have been so far but it's time
time to work on those two areas if I
were you that's what I would do yeah my
dad's a criminal justice Professor I
know that's underpaid I know that's too
low and there's a number of things you
can do across that that far yeah a whole
bunch of stuff you can do with current
criminal justice but but that's not 19
right so I mean and by the way this
that's the that's when when we say that
that's when she says well I really love
working with these kids so I get that
yeah I get that
but right now you can't afford to do
follow your heart or do your passion
thing or whatever Instagram's telling
you to do because you got y'all got
bills what's your job working with a
youth group of the church but that
doesn't make sense right you did work
with youth group of children work a job
that's how you do that you do both you
know you can't mix the two up and be
underpaid it doesn't work so hey man
we're gonna put you guys through
Financial Peace University as our
wedding gift hold on Austin's gonna pick
up and uh we were messing with you
pretty hard but if you listen to what we
said it's going to help you this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
all right foreign
over your head with student loans and
tired of getting calls from collection
agencies if private student loan debt is
taking away your financial peace and you
don't see any way out you need why refi
they're not a debt settlement company
and they're not connected to a bank why
refi refinances defaulted private
student loans that other places won't
touch and gives you a custom loan built
for you based on your ability to pay so
when you refinance your private student
loan debt with why refi you'll have a
payment you can afford with a low fixed
interest rate you couldn't get anywhere
else to help you stick to your budget
and work the debt snowball and you can
save thousands of dollars to learn more
about this custom refinancing option and
a lump sum payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call 8442
MZ or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today hey guys
we would love your help and if you'd
like to help us here's how you can
pretty simple doesn't cost you a thing
but a few moments of your time subscribe
to this show
when you're listening on podcast or
YouTube click the follow button or the
Subscribe button whatever it is uh make
sure you share the show and that can be
clicking a share button or it could be
that you clip the link and send it to
somebody and say Hey listen to this show
make sure you leave a five star review
hit the likes all those kinds of things
like that really help Drive the
algorithms that push the show to the
front of the various platforms that
we're on and we're on almost everything
so thank you for being there we
appreciate you we know that there's a
bazillion of you new in the past six
months based on our numbers and our data
analytics and so forth thank you for
showing up we're glad you're here but
help us by sharing subscribing following
and leaving five star reviews Justin is
in Hattiesburg Mississippi hey Justin
welcome to the Ramsay show
John it is awesome to talk to y'all I'm
excited
absolutely how can we help
so my wife and I are on baby step two
and we're trying to get really gazelle
intents to pay off our debt and I wanted
to see if you and Dr John could speak to
the physical and mental challenge of
working 80 to 90 hours a week on the
physical side being like you know
fatigue lack of sleep and on the mental
side you know your mind is telling you
to call it a day when you still need to
grind out you know those last few hours
to make a really good week
why are you losing sleep you have plenty
of sleep time left
well I guess like you know a day you you
work 16 hours and you have you know an
hour commute and you know eating and
stuff like that you may get you know
five to six and on a longer day you know
make it four hours of sleep
I often see folks try to continue the
life they were living before they went
gazelle intense
and they tried to squeeze it in meaning
I used to watch
um all the shows well now I have to just
watch my two and there's an hour right
there or there's an hour and a half and
I want to go to every single little
league game well during gazelle
intensity you're gonna probably have to
miss some games because you gotta work
some shifts and that's okay because
you're playing a longer game but I would
wonder how much
yeah
how much all in are you yeah that if
there's some of that and
yeah you check your
actual time audit on where your actual
hours are going
um number one
um then
sleep is necessary the second thing
though is is you're not asking yourself
to do this long term this is a short
Sprint
right it's not it's not this is not
sustainable for five years
that's not what we're asking ourselves
to do and I Got a Feeling Just in
talking to you that you have done
uh in the past maybe in sports or
something else you've done something
where you stretched yourself to a limit
and
um if you have if you're a person who's
done that you've experienced what any of
us that have done that uh physical or
mental or otherwise you never return to
the same shape after that that's the
benefit of the stretch
yes sir I have God has really blessed me
with a body that can handle a lot yeah
and so you know once you've done a half
marathon you've done a marathon you've
done a uh uh whatever the the thing is
that pushed you uh physically and
mentally or whatever then you it changes
your level of confidence it changes the
way your swaggered the way you look at
the world after that because you
accomplish the goal and and you know you
break the tape and you're going through
so that that's the way that I have done
it is I number one I look at it as a
short-term play and so it's not going to
kill me because right before you die
from hard work you pass out don't worry
about it I mean it's okay so but the uh
so it's not gonna kill me and uh it's
short term and then the second thing is
is that I'm gonna get more benefits than
just the money in this case you're
you're doing it to make a lot of money
to get out of debt okay but I'm gonna
get character benefits emotional
psychological spiritual benefits even
relational benefits because as a couple
we now know we can do things we didn't
know we could do before as an individual
I know no I can do that because before I
do and it gives me a different level of
well if I can do that then I can do
another thing and if I can do that then
I can do another thing and that's that's
what this is versus being the typical
Fat American sitting on their couch
watching Netflix and never stretches
themselves at all it just there's some
incredible Neuroscience that is
obviously this doesn't um you can't you
can't game then or hack this system but
you've known people who get under a
squat bar and they feel that weight and
they get that weird smile and there's
been people who get under that bar and
it's like ah too heavy and they get off
what are those people says this pain is
gonna be worth this
watch this and the other person says I
need to opt out of this pain right now
and so there's it's the your mindset as
you're driving home you can be like I'm
so tired I hate all this this is the
worst I'm so tired I just clicked
another click how long you've been
married
we've been married five years how's she
doing with all this
um that's interesting you asked that uh
one of the other kind of hard things for
me is like say that she has a day off
and I'm at work you know when it's those
last few hours when I still got you know
four hours left and I'm already tired
and she sends me a text like you know I
miss you ready to see you I'm gonna
think to myself I'm like man I'm ready
to see you too I want to come home but
I'm like you know I need to stay here
another few hours yeah it's like I know
you lost 50 pounds but here's some fresh
baked cookies
[Laughter]
I want you to know
you but I'm in this with you
right and it's real easy for you to be
like oh yeah you know what I mean so
yeah do your best to I mean you're all
in a short Sprint uh do do your best to
roll that out and the good news is she's
not she's not whining about she's not
going oh yeah you never you're never
home with me why aren't you ever home
with me she's not doing that to you she
just said man I miss you I wish you were
here because I'm I'm married to a
country girl it's a hillbilly and if if
they learned one thing at her house
growing up it was unbelievable hard work
she has no patience for people that
won't work hard especially if it was her
husband and so I got the opposite I'm
like get your butt out of here and get
this mess cleaned up what's wrong with
you you know and so it was she kicked me
out the door you know and so yeah
occasionally now when I don't need to
work she's like would you go to work and
get away you know like and so um you
know so the uh uh but she but that so I
had the benefit of a spouse that was
beyond supportive supportive is not the
correct she supported you with her foot
with her foot yeah that's it but I mean
you know in your case you've got a sweet
one that's being sweet and saying I I
miss you but I'm proud of you so you
might even tell her that just go Hey
listen when you do that it it makes me
not angry with you but it makes me angry
with this whole situation it makes it
hard to work five more hours so if you
would do that and just add to the end of
it I'm proud of you you got this it sure
would help me when my wife is pregnant
with Josephine after
um she had we had had Hank she gave me a
list it was not a long list but it was a
short list but she gave me a list of
questions I was not allowed to ask in
the hospital
and when she was in labor and I said why
did you do this and she said because I
know you love me and I know you're going
to ask
how are you feeling does that hurt are
you okay do you need anything and she
said when you ask those questions it
makes me want to strangle you I want to
set my eyeballs on fire just enough to
look at your face your eyeballs right so
she said the best way you can love me is
don't do this I'll let you know if I
need some and so I think for you just
like Dave just said if you let her know
hey when you reach out at ah man I know
you're telling me that you're proud of
me you love me but it just makes me hate
being at work and which makes me hate
myself and makes me hate all this yeah
can you just text me and say I'm so
proud of you and I'll know that you miss
me when you're when you're running the
stadium stairs
um
you you have no memory of doing that
when you look at the scoreboard at the
end of the Super Bowl when you won oh
you make that catch yeah you have no
memory of running the stadium stairs
your brain just your brain allows you to
do the only celebration Justin your stud
man I'm proud of you and I think you're
gonna be okay uh the good news is you're
smart enough to talk about it and say
I'm tired you're smart enough to even
take a look take okay I gotta take a day
I'm done I gotta take at least a day I
can't breathe you know where your limits
are but pushing those limits is not a
permanent thing it's not a way of life
it's a moment in time and the benefits
are going to exceed the pain I can
promise you live like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else
[Music]
thank you
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney number one best-selling
author of the book own your past change
your future is my co-host today thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money Trisha is with us in
Washington D.C hi Tricia welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi thanks for having me
um I have one simple question and one
that's a little bit more complex
um the first is maybe step four fifteen
percent of the income is that based on
the base salary or is that total
including potential bonuses
total gross before taxes
um and then my second question relates
to a second more that I have or a
mortgage that I have jointly with my
mother-in-law or that my husband and I
guess have with my mother-in-law and
whether how we should really be
accounting for that in the baby steps
does that go in bucket two or does that
go in the bucket with the general
mortgage payoff how do you have a
mortgage with your mother-in-law
um so when my husband and I were
expecting our first baby my
mother-in-law was retiring and we wanted
her to move closer to us but she
couldn't afford a house near us and we
thought that you know helping her move
toward where we were would be you know
better than paying for a stranger to do
child care for us so we essentially
assisted her in getting the house so I'm
on the morning so you took out a you're
on her mortgage
um we're jointly on the mortgage we own
it you know 50 50 that's her house
yeah it's her primary residence yes okay
so you took out a mortgage you're a
co-signer in a sense on her mortgage on
her house
uh well I'm on the title as well but
yeah yeah
this is your mom
no it's my husband's mother oh okay so
all three of you are on the title yes
okay
all right uh all right well
so my question basically is do I just
kind of let this linger out there and
make the payments I mean the payments is
fine um are you making the payments
um we split the payments
as a method of helping her
yeah yes and she helps um what happens
to the house when she passes are there
other siblings
um my husband has two siblings we
haven't actually discussed that um what
happens when it passes
um when she passes we haven't discussed
that which is all the money that you're
paying in reducing the principal may go
to them
uh well I'm on the title so I know but
um but you're not you don't have
exclusive title she's got the title too
and her estate will get her portion of
the title and that that portion of the
estate could go to the siblings
sure yeah number one not discussing this
is really bad plan not having a plan is
a really bad plan so we need a will and
a game plan immediately and you may want
to have it where the house is just uh
where the deed is changed and it comes
to you at death
okay okay
um that that would solve a whole lot of
things if you can get control of it like
that then I would put this in your plan
a normal second mortgage on your
residence we tell folks if it's less
than half your annual income put it in
baby step two if it's more than half
your annual income it's in baby step six
so what's the balance on this particular
house although it's not a real second
mortgage
um the balance is 371. oh okay I'm
guessing you're not making 800.
I make after bonus it'll be 500.
household income
uh 500. my husband's retired well I mean
he gets you know thirty thousand times a
whole year for disability but
um yeah you really need to get this
straightened out so that you can get it
paid off but it really is a baby step
six item
okay and
um but but if you pay it off
and there's a paid for house and half of
that house is owned by her and she dies
and there's no will that half of the
house will be split among you and your
sip or your husband and his siblings
mm-hmm yeah dumb plan well and I gotta
Dave I'm gonna ask you a question about
Trisha's situation okay so Trisha I'm
using you your situation as Dave
um what happens if Trisha pays off her
half
but Mom's still making payments it's an
undivided interest there's not enough so
371 is just a total balance of the loan
if you pay down if you paid down 371 by
half
the other she's still liable for the
other half it's not you can you know
it's not two loans it's one loan that's
that's what I mean but Trisha year 371
isn't half of the remaining balance of
the house that's how much the whole
remaining balance is
yeah that's the remaining outstanding
amount on the mortgage so you're not
you're not talking about splitting the
payments with Mom you're talking about
just paying the house off I am
I'm saying pay off the house and but pay
it off and such and when you put the
documentation in place that the house is
yours
yeah that that you know
treat it like it's a rental property
and it's in baby step six and you pay it
off but right now it's not a rental
property right now you start paying it
off you're going to get in an argument
with somebody a judge or a sibling or
both because there's no will and no plan
well there's a will that says just split
it among the three of them oh it's dumb
that's dumb I mean that was not the
intent of this deal that's not a fair
deal here because the others haven't put
anything into this house you should
split the rest of stuff with them or
that's fine but and certainly if you go
and pay off
you know a house that has your name on
it but her name on it's your house and
and it you know that you're benefiting
those siblings if you don't clean this
mess up first so yeah we've got to do
some uh some estate planning work here
and then we need to put it in baby step
six is your overall answer so hey good
question
um
just note I would not have done this the
way you did it I think there was other
ways to help grandmother and help her
move and help her be there to help raise
your kids and all that kind of stuff
without uh getting all tied up in this
barrel of fish hooks that you got
yourself in but you can straighten it
out and by paying it off and by getting
it deeded to you upon death
um or before either one's fine with me
open phones are triple eight eight two
five five two two five GEOS in Miami hi
Geo how are you
hey Dave how are you doing better than
we deserve what's up yeah all right um
so I just had a quick question
um
so I'm thinking about buying a rental
property with my sister
um but she's made it very clear that she
doesn't want a a 15-year cheat we we're
kind of on a time limit
um because my my income of this year is
gonna be like not really that high and
so we're going to be going off on my
income of last year
um and so I was just wondering if it's
going to be a rental and if we're not
really going to be living in it
um and if you know we can potentially
sell it before the 30-year mark this
would be you have three reasons you
should not do this deal
number one you're broke you don't make
enough money to do the deal number two
uh you're you're going to be in a
partnership with someone you're already
in a disagreement with on how to
structure the deal that's Dom
Partnerships are dumb Partnerships with
family can be really bad idea and uh
number three you shouldn't buy rental
property with debt at all
we should pay cash for it
so um but you're kind of new to this
whole Ramsay thing so you didn't know
any I was going to say any of those
things but one of the things we use
around here is the only ship that wants
sales a partnership
because doing 30 years of financial
coaching uh you know what I see a lot
people like you and your sister in my
office both of you pissed off
yeah I can see it yeah because it didn't
because the partnership didn't work yeah
I would tell her I love you enough that
I'm not gonna do this yeah or I'm out
it's not gonna work for me well I mean
you're not making as much money tells me
that you're not you know you're not
making good money you don't need to be
getting in a rental property and you're
financing it and you want to do a 15
because you got at least that much of a
glimpse of the Ramsey stuff uh and she's
like no I want to stay in debt forever
no well it's I I Dave I just keep having
this conversation with folks about my
age a little bit younger a little bit
older
who just keep living on Tick Tock and
they think that they are broke if they
don't have rental property they will
live in a two-bedroom apartment and try
to buy a rental house with a 30 or 40
year note it's Madness yeah it's
heartbreaking what it is it's the it's a
get rich quick syndrome and it's uh this
idea that you know I I'm going to invest
in property uh because that's going to
make me wealthy and the truth is that
real estate does not make broke people
wealthy it makes them broker that's why
they call them brokers and so it's you
know it's just when you're broke real
estate is is a game that you play when
you have cash lots of it because you
need to play the long ball with real
estate and when you get up against the
edge and the Sparks start flying because
there's friction because there's no
margin that's when you're gonna lose
your butt in real estate so I started
with nothing I had four million dollars
for the real estate by the time I was 26
with a million dollar net worth I was
making 200 000 a year in
1980 freaking threes that's a lot of
money back then I lost it all because I
was playing the same stupid butt games
that you people are watching on Tic Tac
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney number one best-selling author
of the book own your past change your
future and and uh host of the Dr John
deloney show on the Ramsay networks
podcast very popular show on
relationships and mental health is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
his new book building a non-anxious life
is on pre-sale you can get it for twenty
dollars and seventy five dollars worth
of goodies thrown in like audiobooks and
ebooks and talks and other things we
include as bonus items all at
ramseysolutions.com right now Linda is
with us in Roanoke Virginia hi Linda
welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you for having me sure what's up
okay so I am I'm currently 6 4 years old
so is my husband
um
I make about 115 my husband makes about
45 and we still owe 180 on our house and
he is not on board with paying the house
off
he I evidently he just does not want to
pay the house off and I've kind of tried
to put my foot down and say you know
when we retire we're not going to have a
house payment
because we're gonna have to sell it and
downsize well he's definitely not on
board with that and
I don't really know how to get them on
board and I did listen to one of your
podcasts and
um where the conversation was about
somebody not being on board and I think
um someone he said this is not a finance
problem this is a marriage problem and I
think that's probably a lot closer than
anything
um
sorry
how long you all been married
29 years how much have you gotten your
uh retirement accounts
my retirement is about
my 401 is
Pro
cracy fund I have two rental properties
that I'm in the process of paying off I
just paid off two of our cars I want one
of the rental properties worth
um together about 200
and what's your homework but
my homework right now it's worth 180.
and you owe 180. yes we owe 180 and it's
worth 180.
well no we we oh we owe on 180 it's
probably worth about
400. okay that's what that makes more
sense okay yeah and does your husband
have any money in Investments at all
no and he doesn't he doesn't participate
in any of my rental properties either
yeah you got a pretty significant
challenge going on in your marriage
yes that's what I was thinking even even
the language that you're using my rental
properties his stuff doesn't do anything
um yeah y'all got yourselves a uh a mess
why won't you how long has he not
participated
um have you all been living Separate
Lives
well we have we we put money we have
separate accounts and we have a house
account our house account goes for all
of the things that we use groceries all
the bills and then we have a savings
account that we put money into to go for
anything major like fixes and and water
heaters or whatever we need to put put
that's exactly that's exactly the
situation I had set up with Buddy and
Craig my two College roommates
that's not that's not a wife or a
husband such that's not a marriage
that's a couple of dudes who are uh
that's a couple of roommates
this is probably true how long has this
been going on 29 years
yeah
so when I bought the right when I bought
the first rental property he did not
want any part of it I sell real estate
on the side also besides being a nurse
and so he didn't want any part of that
one and so I've just been running it
I've almost I only owe 12 000 on it so
I'm getting ready to pay it off next
and then I bought another property
um my daughter-in-law who had cancer was
living in a horrible situation so I went
ahead
and bought a house for her to live in
um which is right near me so I could
kind of help take care of her
and that property is probably about 62
on that one and I'm hoping to get that
paid because I'm snowballing everything
wow
um I'm not sure exactly what to tell you
Linda
this is so painful
um
hey you guys are so disconnected it's
almost as if
um your little brother who had a mental
disability was living with you and you
go and do everything in spite of him
um with a you know because he's not he's
not on board with rental property they
did it anyway he's not on board with
taking care of the kid uh that had
cancer but I did it anyway and he's not
on board with this but I did it anyway
he's an onboard was saving money but I
did it anyway and and I'm the only one
has any assets but I did it anyway and
he makes a fourth of what you make and
he did it anyway
and
and yet you gotta split the mustard in
the refrigerator
yeah I don't I just I don't know what to
do with this except tell you beg you
guys to but guess what this is not gonna
work because I mean you know tell you to
go see a marriage counselor but guess
what he he's not on board he's not gonna
do that what is he on board with and
what what is it he what does he like he
he likes his comfy job and he likes just
living the way he lives
what does that mean
well I mean he goes to work he comes
home he goes to play golf whenever he
gets a chance
that's pretty much it
here's oh man this is gonna be an
umpired person it's going to get me on
trouble with the internet so that's fine
here's what you have to decide
am I going to it's been this way for 30
years and this is going to be this way
for another 30 years
and I'm gonna keep plugging along and
doing my thing
and I'm gonna I'm gonna head on down the
road because this is the life that I
walked into or
I'm gonna cause a Ruckus in my living
room
and turn on the lights and I'm gonna say
this ends today I hope you will come
with me I'm going to a marriage
counselor right
and as a part of going to a marriage
counselor I'm going to learn that I have
value and partnership and I can't do all
this by myself and I'm I can't keep
dragging you and I can't you can't keep
using me as your bank and you can't keep
using me as your sugar mama I need a
husband I don't need another child
and that might mean that I'm out
that might mean um whatever but I think
you have to make that decision for
yourself and if you decide this is the
life I got it's annoying but it is what
it is make peace with it move on down
the road yeah
in which case you're probably selling
your two rental properties to pay off
your home
because if he won't sign the deed you
can't sell that home
and you have 180 000 and you don't have
a hundred and eighty thousand dollars to
pay it off
uh you have 175 near 401k and I guess
she's going to retire and eat out of
your retirement
because he doesn't have any retirement
and you do
and uh I guess the rental properties
that you're going to sell to pay off
your residence
if you make if you attempt to make peace
with it it's going to continue to have
um poor results in your finances
because you're going to have to work
around him again and in order to do that
can't sell the house so I've got to pay
it off and can't pay it off with your
retirement because you don't have any
have enough so those I guess those are
rental properties are going to be sold
you're going to pay it off if you stay
in this but I I wish I had found you 28
years ago I would have had you I would
have
um highly encouraged you to go to a
marriage counselor and deal with this I
don't think you're going to do that now
because I think if you were going to do
that you would have done it a long time
ago
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five all right John
um I can't leave that one alone no one's
bothering me uh that one being if you
were with us in the last segment lady
married 29 years she and her husband
never been on the same page on money and
for that matter on life
um
so I I can't
I don't feel like I can help her I feel
like she's so far in that she's probably
gonna stay in that soup right but but
what I would tell you is this if you're
listening and and John you can throw in
you know whatever you whether you agree
or not or so forth but
um
we have a we have an inordinate number
of people in their 20s listening to the
show and watching this YouTube and
watching us on television and so forth
um
if you are considering entering into a
marriage a lifelong commitment with
someone
and you don't first make sure that
you're in agreement and going to commit
to stay and adjust an agreement on the
subject of money
in-laws because there's crazy and one of
your families or both your family
kids how many to have how to treat them
or like inmate's going to run the Asylum
or what and
um religion these are the four things
that the data tells us if you're in
agreement on these four things before
you're married you have an inordinate
probability I mean like 90 percentile
probability of staying married happily
through your life
but people that are not in agreement on
religion and lost kids and money
live desperate weird toxic lives and are
ineffective at all four of those areas
they're ineffective in their spiritual
walk they're ineffective with their
money and wealth building their
ineffective parents and they're even
ineffective family members to their
extended family because they're not in
agreement
I'm gonna I'm gonna help my mama even if
you don't want me to you know they're
not in agreement
and and you live your life in angst
because you don't have alignment on
these basic things please for God's sake
don't call it love to marry someone that
you are not aligned with like that
it's not love
it's drugs it's alcohol it's something
it's permanent roommate lust but you're
gonna you're gonna end up with a
roommate that you don't like
I think that I think beneath those four
things is
equally important because I'm thinking
about this like on all four issues my
wife and I were aligned and we are
different on a num probably three of the
four maybe four of the four this 21
years later I think
being in alignment out the gate and
equally important being in line with
what hap how are we gonna act what's our
process for when we get across because
you will get crossed I want to help Mom
I don't want to help your mom all right
now the alignment is do you just do what
you're gonna do how do we yeah how do we
lay how do we set this problem in front
of us and we tackle it together and you
gotta have a plan to go forward in that
last call I don't want you I don't want
you retiring I don't want to downsize I
don't want to do this I don't do this I
just want to play golf
and you make three times what I make so
I'm just gonna take the money and we're
gonna put all in the same pot
man that's gonna do this cashed out
right that's the guy that there was no
alignment not only on issues but on how
do we actually solve problems when they
pop up in our marriage and they pop up
in every marriage yeah if you're
listening to the show and you're 24 and
you're dating and you don't take a clue
from how miserable that lady is
there that's what we want you to do
that's why we're coming back to this is
we go you know you have got to make this
a priority it's not a business
transaction it's a values transaction
because if when you can agree on your
money you've agreed on your dreams
you've agreed on your fears you've
agreed on your life
and when you can't agree on your money
you're not agreeing on the basics of
life and you won't sleep and you will
not ever have peace not by yourself not
with your friends not with anybody it
haunts you it haunts you it increases
the likelihood of addictions it
increases the likelihood of sexual
dysfunction in the marriage and
increases all of this okay so these
things are so intricately tied together
that you guys have got to be grown-ups
quit you know this is not a this is not
a Hallmark movie doofus and it's about
your life on my show people call in and
I they're so nervous if I say what I
need out loud he might leave and my
response is always well good
you deserve more than that and I know
you're going to be lonely and I know
it's scary and I know it's frustrating
and uh there's a great comedian he said
the worst part about breaking up
long-term relationships is
um there's no there's no equity rollover
you can't tell your your new your uh
it's Michael Che you can't tell your
your new girlfriend hey I went to her
wedding her sister's wedding I ain't
going to this one like I could carry
that up you don't get to care you gotta
start over again I get that it's all
it's terrible and
the alternative is you spend the next 30
Years
looking at your bank account so scared
to death you can't breathe and you look
over there and there's this lump on us
on a couch getting his golf shoes on
yeah
for God's sakes if you you know if if if
you look up and you're completely
misaligned you're going to you know
you're going to end up liking them
they're not gonna end up liking you at
the end of the story so you gotta resent
them you might as well just call it now
yeah I mean early
and before you end up in marriage before
you you know so please folks and and for
those of you that have got young
marriages you know you've been married
two or three years and you're struggling
to get to get aligned on these things go
sit down with a marriage counselor
you know it forgot he forgot sakes if
you wanted to lose weight and and you
know become fit you would hire a
personal trainer so why can't you hire a
marriage trainer or if your breath
smells bad you go to the dentist a
professional yeah why so why can't you
hire a marriage trainer you know go you
know or maybe a good start for that has
come to the marriage and money weekend
that we're doing with the John deloney
and Rachel Cruz that's coming up
um in October in October I'm looking
around here trying to figure out the
date but yeah
um
yeah that's 19 to 21 yeah thank you I'm
trying to grab the cheat sheet so I'll
get my act together here but yeah okay
19-21 here in Nashville it'll be at the
Ramsey uh Event Center I didn't think
about that but you could come do that
weekend that weekend's going to be
pretty intense I think ultimately in
fact I was doing a podcast earlier today
somebody do that weekend as a
pre-marriage thing you could you could
and here's why because you're going to
be surrounded by people who've been
married for 25 years and for 15 years
and so you're gonna get to see some
couples down the road and I think when
people catch them at the break and have
a cup of coffee yeah that's right or you
can listen to the but the the challenges
the content's not inappropriate for
every minute
if you said I do come on in okay or
you're about to that's right but I but I
think the at the end of the day
avoidance cannot be a strategy it can
avoidance when you're dating avoidance
I'm just not going to look at my budget
well the thing I always think about Les
Perry when he says in Dr Les parents
says you know when you have these uh
strong feelings about something and you
bury them they have a high rate of
Resurrection they will show up they'll
pop back out and they come back out in
the most inopportune ways the most
inopportune moments uh and and it takes
another five years of therapy to figure
out why they're coming out sideways and
while you're yelling at your kid when
actually it's it's a decision back over
here whatever the thing is but yeah
absolutely yeah so please folks please
do not move forward in these
relationships if you're sitting there in
your three year in a three-year marriage
um you know
how cause a ruckus I'm not going to tell
you what John says I do not I'm not
going to tell you to go with the
possibility of uh make peace with it
don't make peace with it you've been
there for three years Raise Hell
getting a marriage counselor's office
Raise Hell about it we're going to get
on the same page or I'm going to call
everybody's going to be miserable and
I'm going to be the cause until we get
on the same page I am this is not okay
I'm not gonna live like this the worm
has turned cause a Ruckus get in there
and do the work and figure this out and
find your voice and you know you you can
be as loud or whatever you don't need to
be loud but I mean you can be as bold or
raw as you want to be but cause a Ruckus
it's worth it because it's the only
method to get to healing and let me make
this statement to my fellow gentlemen
out there you can cheat on your wife
with a golf club
and you can commit infidelity with your
job
and so this idea that well I'm I'm all
good I'm following the rules I don't
participate I don't do nothing that's
cheating that is cashing out
yeah you're leaving your wife even
though you're sleeping in the same house
it's a manhood crisis the worst
Suffocation of America you're acting
like a little boy instead of a man throw
your shoulders back and serve your
family
you self-centered twerp this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us netsuite worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
Dr Toronto Delaney Ramsey personality is
my co-host today hey guys we got a great
radio partner in Phoenix the legendary
KTAR FM number one talk radio station in
Phoenix and we're blessed to be
part of their daily lineup their 15th
annual give-a-thon for Phoenix
Children's is taking place through
Friday the 18th last year they raised a
record two million dollars you can
donate and in the Phoenix area or if
even if you just want to help kids in
the Phoenix area by texting the word
give to
411-923 with a medical staff of nearly 1
000 Specialists Phoenix Children's is
one of the largest Pediatric Health Care
Systems in the country in 2023 U.S news
and World Report named Phoenix
Children's to its list of best
children's hospitals for the 13th
consecutive year so again if you're in
the Phoenix Market in particular but
anywhere and you want to uh you want to
flex that generosity muscle this is a
good cause it's the annual giveathon for
KTAR FM for Phoenix Children's and you
texted the word give to 41192
to three our question of the day is
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services summer is busy which makes
it hard to find time for Home
Maintenance but neighborly is your
source for local home repair
professionals like Air Serv Mr Electric
and dryer vent wizard go to
neighborly.com to be ready for any
season all right today's question comes
from Ryan in Virginia Ryan writes I have
some friends that are trying to achieve
Financial Freedom through retailing MLM
products online and networking with
other MLM multi-level marketing
retailers they are a very sweet very
sincere but seemingly very innocent
couple I think you mean innocent as in
naive naive the wife does take on
occasional outside work currently but I
wonder how much of her income is
absorbed back into trying to make their
MLM business work I haven't yet asked
them what their net annual revenue
income is from the MLM they've been at
it for two years or if they keep track
of actual hours put into their business
what's an hourly wage Etc but before I
do I want to ask if mlms are still the
Shady barely legal pyramid schemish
companies they used to be or what your
views on mlms are I haven't found much
good said about them online what do you
think about them and what might you
suggest in way of having a conversation
with my friends about it
um
Federal Trade Commission
says that 99 of the people that join an
MLM lose money
that's a staggering statistic it's hard
to actually believe I'm not sure I do
believe it
um the AARP did a different study that
came with different numbers came with
different results so I haven't looked
into the methodologies on the studies to
tell you but they say that
um 27 of the people that join an MLM
actually make a profit
um and that 70 you know whatever the
balance is 73 percent lose money uh not
quite as uh harsh as the FTC number but
um I think if you've just got good
walking around sense and you've got a
few decades under your belt you can we
can all agree that the vast majority of
people that started in MLM do not make
money they lose money whether it's well
in excessive half so there's a high
probability that this couple
statistically speaking has actually lost
money but then has made no money for the
hours they've invested so
um and that's just a observation that's
not actually a moral statement it's not
an ethic statement I'm not saying
whatever what did he say here barely
legal pyramid schemish that's I'm not
saying any of that the bottom line is
just the people that get in generally
don't make it
um and so it generally makes the top
five percent of the people in the thing
uh they make all their money off of
recruiting and uh people buying the kits
that uh or whatever it is they buy when
they become a recruit and you know or
sign up for the licensing or whatever it
is they have to do and the uplines make
money on that or they go
um
they go sell what you know the
methodology generally what happens is
life insurance companies do the same
thing uh they hire someone young and
inexperienced uh with absolutely very
little uh belief that that person is
going to be with them for 10 years but
they use them to get to their closest
Circle of Friends their Uncle John and
their uh you know their grandpa Dave and
they use them to get an appointment
because they couldn't get in to see John
or Dave but when you know the nephew
calls up is just out of college and he's
24 we'll let them come over with because
he's in training with his boss and so
they'll come over and Pitch your life
insurance it's called working your
natural market and but when they use up
the uh the person's uh call list of what
they call their natural market the
people that they actually have
credibility with then they've they've
run their course and the person can't
make money and so 80 percent of the
people that join the life insurance
world to sell life Insurance are out of
the business in one year and that's not
a multi-level thing it's life insurance
so
um but it's the same concept here they
work your natural market so they recruit
someone and then takes it you take them
to Mom and Daddy you take them to your
brother you take them to your high
school friend uh who will let you in the
door but they wouldn't let anybody else
in the door otherwise and you could
recruit them or you sell them makeup or
whatever it is you're going to sell them
whatever the multi-level is doing right
um and so I do personally know
a handful of people that have made Seven
figures in that World
um I know another guy who got so he used
to speak for him all the time got so
disillusioned with the fact they were
making more money selling books to the
motivational books and tapes to Their
audience than they were running the
actual business the business was like a
seminar business behind the scenes and
he he was part of it because he was one
of the speakers and he got so
disillusioned with that he quit he
wouldn't speak for him anymore and he's
a professional speaker and author to
this day and you'd know his name if I
named it but he won't he won't work with
him anymore but he worked with him for
years he was very well known in their
ranks and so all of that to say
um
if you tell me you're in an MLM because
it's a great part-time job I'll tell you
statistically you're a fool
if you tell me you're in an MLM because
you want to grow a large sales
organization and you have a skill set
that helps you to become a sales manager
to 100 or to a thousand people uh or 100
people that have a hundred people that
have a hundred people I'm going to tell
you might get rich you might be one of
the handful that makes a ton of money
but in the meantime the people that join
are inordinately bothersome to the rest
of us
you hate to see them coming don't you it
can be pretty tough it can be pretty
tough oh you're going to be nice about
this aren't you well I it can be real
tough
um I always appreciate the young kids
when they're hustling and trying to sell
me Cutco or something
runs the exact same model too not
multi-level but they run the work the
Natural Market yeah I mean I always
appreciated some this yeah they get
their dads so I got a lot of their dead
gum knives because Sharon won't keep
them out of my house but it I think one
of the most bother them bothering some
great knives yeah they're incredible
nice bother some things about this
question is
um that if Ryan was sitting with me the
guy who wrote in and asked this question
I would say hey have they ever even
asked you your opinion yeah because this
guy sounds like he's spending a ton of
time
um he's already made up his mind
wondering what their finances are like
and whether they're making the right
decisions whether they're doing with it
like man you don't get a vote unless
they ask you in and so if they ask you
in
then you can give your opinion but man
it doesn't sound like they're asking you
in it sounds like you're just waiting
for a chance to say hey what you're
doing is wrong and evil in bed and
you're gonna lose money and what are you
doing yeah that's true yeah you're those
convinced against their will are of the
same opinion still and talking someone
that's in an MLM out of being in one is
about like trying to get somebody that
loves crypto to not buy crypto or to
argue somebody out of their religious
stance this is not gonna work or who
they vote for yeah
I mean Trump has caused all kinds of
problems climate change everything else
well people that hate Trump hate him for
for things he never even did it's
amazing everyone hates every politician
for things they never really did that's
true I saw a great one the other day it
was uh it was like a library and Obama
was sitting at a table and he had a
chocolate chip cookie and a glass of
milk and he picked it up and the
chocolate chip cookie was way too big
and he tried to dip it in the milk and
he got all mad and he goes thanks Obama
yeah everybody plays everybody for
everything all the time he blames
himself he's loving to somebody else
right so I I just I'm with you I'm with
you yeah so yeah I agree with John in
that sense Ryan mind your own business
it's not your problem yeah but um let's
say yes but what do we think about mlms
uh in general I'm not mad at them if you
want to go do one be prepared to be a
recruiter and a sales trainer and and be
prepared to manage a high turnover
organization and if you want to do that
and that's your call you have a chance
of making this into a career and making
money none of them are good part-time
jobs statistically
[Music]
um and so you can do a lot better things
on your side hustle this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's back they're one
they're watching guarantee and
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Rachel is with us in South Bend Indiana
hi Rachel welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call sure
um me and my husband we are 41 years old
we've been married for 21 years and then
baby steps four five and six perfect and
we still yeah we still really like each
other
um we have two school age kids and yes
yesterday we argued about the
temperature on the thermostat it was a
little cold
um so we
um I work about six days a month and my
husband works about nine days a month we
enjoy our days off together I work as a
nurse practitioner in the emergency
department and he's a firefighter
paramedic
um my question is
um being where we are we are paying more
on our mortgage in the last five years
we've lost about seven friends on the
fire department
um but the oldest one being 54 I'm not
super emotional but some of those losses
were very close firefighters aren't
known for their longevity in their house
just because of the carcinogens they're
exposed to
my question is I feel I almost need
permission for my dad and my brother
here to say it's okay to be intentional
for a season
um and enjoy life we're not going crazy
we stick to our budget
um you know I did go over ten dollars on
dining this month
um but the new budget starts tomorrow
um
so I guess I I know that I'm as my
husband jokes with me that I'm worth so
much more it's a joke
um but I feel bad sometimes that um
knowing that I could bring in another
bring in more income and bring in more
wealth but at the same time balancing
enjoying the life and the season that we
have okay to be very to be very clear
with the the current hours that you're
working is what you would like to work
you just don't want to feel guilty about
them and during the number of hours that
the two of you are working now you're
able to fund your retirement put money
aside for kids college and baby step
five and pay extra on your mortgage did
I understand that correctly
correct okay so your only question is do
we accelerate our
net worth increase accelerate our wealth
building by working more and we don't
really want to right now is that your
question
that is my question it's almost like I
feel like
um you do not need to feel guilty at all
okay okay because what we tell folks to
do is exactly what you're doing be very
intense
sell everything sacrifice everything to
get out of debt build an emergency fund
that's baby steps one two and three and
then when you get to here you're
supposed to go from intense as you
mentioned to intentional and by being
intentional with the income that you
have you are living very responsibly and
by the way you're going to become
wealthy it's just going to take you a
little longer oh and by the way you
probably will gear up your hours later
when different things happen in your
life right and I want to when my kids
are both in high school I'm like okay
then I can work eight to ten days
nobody says you have to so no no what
you're saying is you feel like the
trade-off is fair for the hours versus
the quality of life right now and within
the within the confines of again saying
it one more time being responsible and
you're already doing all of that the
only question is do we want more wealth
faster and right now the trade-off's not
worth it to us that's our intentional
decision I think it's wonderful it's
what we teach you to do
okay great hey Rachel you did that yeah
can I ask you a question
sure
um
there's something else here is that fair
or let me ask you I'll just be more
direct who's pushing this
do you do you want your husband to not
be a firefighter anymore
no he loves it that's not what I asked
you
no I don't and he felt like I really
love like he loves it and I love him
being a firefighter I love that we speak
the same language when he comes home and
has a hard day at work I know what it's
like I know what it's like in the ER to
lose a kid on a job and I love that he
understands like it is just like we both
truly love our jobs
um and we joke that maybe we love it so
much because we're not slaughtered and
burnt out by it
um but no I oh I can't imagine him being
anything else I truly
love him being a firefighter I mean yes
I think about at times like oh man I
hope he doesn't die in a fire
um but man he's always like if I'm
frightened a fire and then I meet my
savior
um then I'm a millionaire nobody tells
me yeah and that sounds good I mean that
that sentiment sounds good and that hug
feels nice but
like you said you have you have a
ringside seat you've seen what it's like
when there's um a wife leaning over a
bed in hospital and he's gone you've
been there and you've imagined yourself
in that seat here's why I'm asking that
because what you're the guilt you're
feeling is trusting your instincts
you're trusting yourself and we often
lose trust in ourselves when we're
living in a chaotic system and we are in
chaotic systems when either a we're
doing what y'all do you know we're both
First Responders and that's just the
nature of the Beast and you'll try to
shake the trauma every day yeah yeah you
are a secondary trauma package like you
have the you have the front row seat
there
um or
you haven't fully come out and said hey
this this your job is killing me and if
that's not the case I don't put that out
in the universe that's awesome then that
tells me that you're doing what you all
need to do to stay sane and well and
good and I'm going to high-five you as
one of the bravest couples you can
because it's real easy to look at that
dollar amount and go chase it versus I
want to
um make sure that we are filling up our
picture so that when we go all in
helping these people because that's what
we were put on Earth to do we are fully
ready to rock and roll yeah and and for
the person out there that's listening
that wants to use this conversation is
an excuse to uh I I I just I wouldn't be
intentional and then I'm going to
intentionally go into debt and I'm going
to intentionally not meet my budget
that's not who what we're talking about
Rachel and her husband are making their
budget they're making they're putting
money into retirement they're paying
extra on their mortgage they're being
responsible the only question is how
fast do we do more that is a different
conversation than we're just freaking
using
the quality of life I'm worried about
quality of life when somebody says that
I generally translate that as lazy
that's because your heart is small
that's right and shriveled that's it and
the Grinch the Grinch the money Grinch
That's me yeah and uh no I think there's
time for I think there's times for
sacrifice and I think that on both sides
of the fence yeah
I think there's sacrifices all across
the board but
I also man she's not that she's not
she's not in in the sacrifice mode
doesn't need to be uh and she's not lazy
and she's not any of that so she's not
irresponsible i I'm completely on board
she's in the guilt industrial complex
they will find a way to make you feel
guilty about
taking care of yourself and your family
yeah and she did say something about her
father and her brother are questioning
their choice or something but they don't
get a vote nope don't get a vote so
that's how that works yeah so here's the
weird thing you wouldn't intentionally
do something that's irresponsible
those are those you know what happens
there is someone's justifying their
rationalizing they're going you know
we've heard it actually twice in the
last two hours I was forced when he says
you know bought a car it was an
emergency I had to I had to no you
didn't it was 30 000 car you have to do
that you know it's you don't have to do
that you weren't forced to buy a car
that's dumb you know but but what
happens is you build up the drama and
the hyperbole in your head that's not
intentionality that's just drama and
hyperbole it's reactive and and it's
immaturity and it's impulsive whether
you're 56 or whether you're 26 you're
being a child and you're using the fact
that well it was uh I had several
unfortunate things happen well welcome
to walking around most of us do you know
but generally that that word unfortunate
it's like enforced and it was an
emergency and I was trapped and there's
this fatalistic thing that goes around
all that and you know that's not
intentional
intentional is we we can see things
coming we have a little bit of vision
out there for the future we know we're
going to retire so we need to set some
money for retirement these kids are
aging out so we need some money for
their college you know we we're going to
have to buy a car because this one's on
its last leg so when you start saving
for that that's intentional and
responsible
because most of this stuff really does
not sneak up on you people by the way
they just announced that this year last
week Christmas this year is in December
no
no you're just a minute yeah don't let
it sneak up on you watch Christmas sneak
up on people it's all right you know
or the millions of people October 15th
that will but we'll say wait what what's
our loans are due what our student loans
what student loans even the government
came out ahead of time what
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsay
personality number one best-selling
author of the book own your past change
your future and host of the Dr John
deloney show
a world famous podcast on the Ramsay
networks is my co-host today open
phone's a triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jennifer is with us in
Detroit Michigan hi Jennifer how are you
better than I deserve what's up
my question revolves around my father
actually so a little bit of a backstory
my my mom would always be a financial
person in the house she passed away
about 10 years ago and since then my dad
has come to me for most of his financial
decisions I'm on your path um I'm 41
um my house is half paid off now I have
zero Consumer Debt
um is he is he doing what you're telling
to do
not exactly oh okay so he comes to you
ask your advice then does what he wants
to do
about half of what I you know he'll do
about half how very dad of him yeah six
months later he'll say well you told me
you know I'm fixing the players well you
told me I'm like that I'm like you
didn't hear the other half of it you're
starting to realize that your mom wasn't
as crazy as you thought aren't you
and so for me to be able to sleep at
night um I I need I want to get so I'll
tell you the situation the advice that I
want to give him and for me to sleep at
night I just want to make sure that I'm
giving him the right information okay um
since he's in he's in a different place
you know in his financial journey and
age obviously than I am
um I said I'm 41. I have a teenage
children it's a different story but how
old is your dad he is uh he'll be 65
next month and how much money does he
have
he was looking at retirement
um he currently at this moment has a 121
000 in the bank
um he uh owes 127 on the house
um which is worth about 425.
um so my advice to what he sprung on me
does he have does he have a retirement
account
uh no this 120 is what he's planning on
retiring on which is actually so he
doesn't have much money okay
well which was actually a
that he got at work for 150 about two
years ago and he's just been sitting out
your mom's been dead 10 years and he's
not been saving any money
wow okay
a hundred thousand dollars from her life
insurance and paid off
um you know uh an equity loan that they
have in the house paid off car you know
paid off cars uh reduces drugs but he's
not saving any money okay correct
correct so he the other day he comes to
me and he says I found a house I want to
buy it's 120 000 I can pay cash for it
isn't this great and I said that is
great give me more details
um then he tells me it's uh which I have
nothing wrong with it's a you know it's
a double wide in a trailer park okay
nothing wrong with it no no what I have
wrong with it is that it also comes with
a 700 a month uh lot rent payment I got
a lot wrong with it
yeah
well yeah
yeah because I don't like trailers or
people that live in them I just don't
like things that go down in value
exactly so he's only got a hundred
thousand dollars to his name and he's
going to buy a depreciating asset with
it that's dumb and have to pay 700 a
month for the for the opportunity to
lose to lose money
thank you
so he you know I thought that you I I
said you if you were a little bit
aggressive you are you have a six
thousand dollar difference between what
you have in the bank versus what you
could do to pay your house off with and
he's like but but then I don't have any
money and I'm like but then you have a
thousand dollars that you're not
spending every month that you would keep
you would start building up that fund
again with
um I mean I I'm all for him wanting you
know selling the house and downsizing he
does not need a 425 000 house and
downsizing into a house or a condo
that's going to go up in value right you
know I even told him I said if you had
come to me and said this is the best
neighborhood ever they have all these
amazing amenities and it's worth 700 a
month
I but it's not he's doing this with the
mindset thinking he has to have cash in
the bank so he sells the house he'll you
know net about a 300 000. and he thinks
he's sitting pretty the problem is he's
still paying 700 he's he's trading off a
thousand dollars
you know what a 20-year trailer is what
20 year old trailers are worth
nothing okay actually probably less than
nothing because you probably have to pay
to have it moved yeah nothing they go
down in value why not take the same
hundred and fifty thousand bucks and buy
a nice little condo or a nice little
cabin somewhere
she passed that he's gonna sell the
house
um well I mean the answer the question
is you're not going to talk him out of
it it doesn't sound like it sounds like
it's one of the 50 of the stupid things
you tell him to do he shouldn't do he
does anyway and he's probably going to
do it so I can't stop him you can't stop
him I don't know why we're having this
discussion but the but the point is the
you know should anyone buy a 100 000
trailer
no
there's not an instance in which I would
tell you to do that not a single one
because what is that trailer worth 10
years from now less much less what is
that trailer or mobile home manufactured
doesn't matter if it had wheels on it
bubba this is what it is it's a car you
sleep in it goes down in value and I'm
sorry for those for those of my friends
that are in the mobile home industry but
you produce a product that goes down in
value so I'm not going to tell people to
put a hundred thousand dollars in
something that goes down in value
particularly when they only have a
hundred thousand dollars to their name
now if you want to go buy a hundred
thousand dollar
car
and you have 20 million dollars
okay you can afford to burn a hundred
thousand dollars
you can afford that and that's fine but
this guy can't afford to lose the
hundred thousand dollars and you know in
the name of I'm going to move down now
you're going to move all the way into
the cellar no and no I'm not a snob I'm
not too good to live in a trailer it's
not shut up you poor mothers don't even
bring that up that is not the case the
situation is simply this the stupid
things go down in value don't buy them
now Jennifer I mean I don't have much
planer you can make it or I can make it
to where your dad's actually going to
listen but please don't buy a hundred
thousand dollar trailer that goes down
in value and for God's sake don't pay
700 a month for the opportunity to lose
this
to rent
the lot so what's the difference I'm
trying to think of of somebody who's
listening to the show and they're trying
to find uh a red flag what's the
difference in buying a mobile home for
100 grand and renting
at a thousand bucks a month
you're not losing money
you're just paying for a service and
number one number one we're not telling
we don't tell people to rent for a
decade yeah we tell them to rent for a
period of time till they get out of debt
have an emergency fund and then are able
to get a home okay we renting as a way
of life for 40 years is not something
I'm going to sign you up for that's
right buying a home is something I'm
going to sign you up for and buying a
trailer to live in for 30 or 40 years
because that well that's what I kind of
afford no no you can't afford it you
can't afford to lose that much money
it's going down in value you're losing
money more than the rent much more than
the rent and uh and you can't get out of
them when you're in them either you
can't sell them you'd be stuck like a
timeshare this oh God see not not enough
time not enough time this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hey those of you guys out there checking
in on Ramsey let me kind of give you an
update on a couple of things happening
we appreciate you being here all month
long we're giving away cash
that's pretty cool you could win up to a
500 weekly Prize or the grand prize of
three thousand dollars this month
ramseysolutions.com giveaway uh while
you're there you can check out the
twelve dollar sale
um Total Money Makeover from paycheck to
purpose on your pass change your future
just a couple of our number one best
sellers that are on sale all of them
just about are you can pre-order Dr John
Delaney's brand new book building a
non-anxious life for twenty dollars get
seventy five dollars worth of free bonus
items all of this is happening at
ramseysolutions.com the other thing
that's happening is uh if you haven't
heard the student loans are coming back
online and you're going to start paying
payments and interest in October people
are freaking out they don't know what to
do well that's when Ramsay's at our best
we're here to help you with your freak
out we are going to do a uh a student
loan live stream on September the 12th
and we want you to be part of it it's me
and Rachel Cruz and Jade washout Jay
paid off over 2 thousand dollars worth
of student loans Rachel Cruz and I have
worked with um millions of you over the
years to get you out of student loan
debt and uh you're going to have to face
this we're going to talk about how we
got into this student loan mess the
student loan debt in America how we got
here and how we get out
September 12th at 7 pm a free live
stream go to ramseysolutions.com student
loans sign up for the free live stream
John deloney and Rachel Cruz will be
doing the money and marriage getaway
there are a few tickets left it is about
sold out here in Nashville October 19
and 21. it's a whole weekend long event
several days a three-day deal right
right it's a full-on marriage Retreat
yeah and it's uh be held here at the
Ramsey Event Center but we've got all
kinds of
very interesting curriculum and content
that you do not want to miss it's a
party it was gonna be a blast it's gonna
be a lot of fun yeah one thing about
John and Rachel being there it'll be
funny you can just count on it and it'll
be expensive
money and marriage getaway October 21 19
and 21. uh and the whole gang will be in
Chicago those of you in that area just a
little north of Chicago up on the Willow
Creek Campus we're going to be doing an
event there on September 15 and 16 just
a few weeks away the smart conference uh
Friday evening all day Saturday talking
about how to get the career on track
mental health issues John will be
dealing with we'll certainly be dealing
with money issues and student loan
issues on that day as well the smart
conference Chicago September 15 16. so
that's a bunch of stuff going on around
Ramsey right now you can find all of it
at ramseysolutions.com stop by there and
we would love to have you a lot of the
things I just mentioned are very
inexpensive or they're free so uh pretty
cool now the VIP stuff for the smart
conferences also sold out but there is
some general admission tickets and we
would love to have you and we have some
special programs to upgrade you if you
come in on GA might end up might end up
somewhere else so be sure and check that
out again Chicago 15 September 15 and
16. Joe's in Ann Arbor Michigan hi Joe
welcome to the Ramsey Show
Hi how are you better than I deserve
what's up
um so my girlfriend and I we own a
duplex uh we bought in 2020 around
October
um and we were thinking about moving uh
somewhere else apparently we live in the
bottom half and we were renting the top
unit
um up until recently our our last 10 had
just moved out
um we kind of don't I don't want to say
we're over the landlord life but um
we're not sure if we want to use the
space
um for you know we both work from home
so we're considering using it as like a
home office
um or renting it out or just moving
entirely and
either renting out both units and taking
that income towards whether whatever we
decide to either rent or buy
um
or
um selling it completely and just moving
away from it and buying something
um new so
that's the one you're gonna do because
you already decided that for you called
me you're done homie
what's that sell it yeah yeah you're out
you're done you everything in your
language your voice tone everything said
you were done
you're ready to move and have a fresh
new clean thing and you don't want
Runners anymore it's all over you it's
often often people call and we're trying
to talk them out of their hysteria
because what they're proposing with the
real estate deal is insane you're the
exact opposite you've already you've
already said you want someone to tell
you you're not insane you're not insane
I would sell the crap out of this thing
and I mean in three years I think we
paid 164 we've done some Renovations
we've improved the kitchen and the
backyard and everything so I think we
could maybe make some money off of it
probably sell it for 200 something yeah
good
um but also the area that we're living
in is kind of developing they're doing a
lot of you know you know the roads Joe
yeah you're over it
don't talk yourself back into it you're
not going to talk me into it you're over
it yeah this is how ulcers are formed
when reality is in front of you and
you're like yeah but one time they're
gonna Edge and they're gonna put a curb
in you know let me tell you man I I got
a in a real estate business I was 18
years old and this old man had this uh
piece of property that was about five
miles from the commercial area it was a
piece of piece of farmland and um he
wanted like a million dollars for it it
was worth a hundred thousand and he said
but but it's someday it's going to be
commercial
it's been 40 years
it just now turned commercial he died a
decade ago but it just now turned
commercial I mean you know so you can
you can what if if ands and buts and all
that the rest of your life on real
estate it always moves at a different
speed than we think it's going to faster
or slower doesn't matter none of that
matters you're done with this situation
it aren't you right aren't you well
emotionally you're done with it
well the one thing is just living
underneath yeah
you don't have to apologize it's okay we
move and we rent both if you listen to
the show I tell people not to buy
duplexes with a tenant next door but if
you're going to you must understand the
good news is your tinnitus next door you
can find them the bad news is your
tenant is next door they can find you
right and that's what you discovered
right
well the the one situation I wanted to
ask is if we move out can we rent the
bottom and the top and we're no longer
there and we're using that income
towards you know a rental or something
is that not worth it it's not worth the
headache or rental property is fine but
Joe doesn't like renters
yeah it's a it's a lot I mean yeah oh
Joe I'm not talking about everybody else
and I'm not talking about the concept of
investment real estate I'm talking about
you
you're done yeah you don't want this
anymore
someday later you may want to be a
landlord again but right now
um you've had your you've had your trip
on the crazy train and you're tired of
the Crazy Train
that's true yeah yeah that's okay take a
break from crazy go get you a house and
by the way don't buy a house with
somebody you're not married to again
okay well you're gonna get bit you're
gonna get bit if you listen if you're
gonna buy a house with her put a ring on
it buddy because you're gonna get
yourself in a mess legally
because you can't break up with a house
you can break up with a girl
but the house both of you own together
and you don't have the benefit of
divorce court for the judge to tell you
what to do because you are not in a
marriage you are in a partnership
without any partnership documents
and so if she just decides to run off
tomorrow to wherever Timbuktu and you
can't find her oh well you own a house
and you can't sell it because you be
stuck I know she's not gonna go crazy
but those tenants were going to be easy
to work with that was passive income and
so things don't always turn out exactly
like we think they're going to please
for God's sakes don't buy another house
with somebody you're not married to
people stop doing that you get we see
people in our dad gum counseling offices
every week financial
disasters getting foreclosed on they
should be able to sell the house there's
plenty of equity but we can't find said
X
who spun out and took off and wasn't
married to and we would not have jobs if
it wouldn't if it didn't happen to you
yep it can always happen to you that's
what makes us so relevant
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for being with us America we're so
glad you're here open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Devin is in Portland Oregon hi Devon how
are you
hey Dave um yeah thanks for checking my
call I guess I could start this off with
uh you know I got a lot of respect for
you um
kind of nervous and excited to talk to
you at the same time so
no thank you how can we help
well so I guess trying to sum things up
here the best that I can without giving
my whole entire life story I got out
about a year ago about a 10 year long
relationship and uh the last like three
years of that 10 year long relationship
were pretty much just like a downhill
coming to the end and it was a lot of
denial on my part and um
so having said that within those three
years you know I basically I went from
like pretty pretty good standing
um financially sitting and then uh
basically just kind of burned my life
down to the ground because I found you
know I could find some type of happiness
and buying stuff and so over the last
three years I got myself and and some
dad
um and I guess to add on to that and one
thing I didn't tell the guy over the um
your uh one of that guy that that
basically I've been working with to even
talk to you and
um is that
also around that time
I was given the opportunity to assume my
grandparents loan for their house and
their property but that's something they
want to give me is kind of an inherence
thing
um
and I I drug my feet on it
um but it was also at the same time that
the whole
my past relationship is starting to fall
apart
and so I just basically spiraled
um and then from there everything kind
of fell apart and I'm just now kind of
rebuilding my life the last year I found
a new woman
um in the world it's she's straight up a
blessing from God
and we're actually getting ready to get
married here pretty soon and so
I'm not really in the financial
situation
um and like I have this urgency that I
need to get this thing done with the
house as fast as possible
um but I'm not financially able to do at
this moment
and uh my credit isn't as good as it was
back when I first got approached this
idea
um so I don't know I guess I'm just kind
of my life right now is kind of along
the chaotic side between the marriage
thing and also just you know this real
sense of uh how can we best help you
well I guess what would you do in my
situation
um
do you know much about loan assumptions
like do you have to have super great
credit I mean what well you have to have
enough you have the same credit as if
you're going to get a loan because you
have to you're basically taking out a
loan so I've never had a house before
yeah
um not sure you need a house uh the
um
okay so here's the thing what you're
describing and you use the word a couple
of times and you described it well is
chaos
yeah and so you know what we would want
for you is to move from chaos towards
order
and what that involves usually is
simplifying things and cleaning things
up
right yeah and uh and and making real
clear decisions some of those decisions
are a yes some of those decisions are no
um and so on so uh
and I think that's the biggest way you
can be a blessing uh and talk about
being a real husband getting married
congratulations by the way so how much
debt have you run up Devin
you know in the grand scheme of things
it probably doesn't sound like a whole
lot Evan how much debt have you run up
um right about 45 Grand okay on what
uh Death By A Thousand Cuts all sorts of
different stupid language to Yo in your
car
none no no okay so what is the majority
of this credit cards
the credit cards
um yeah basically okay so you were
medicating the Pain by buying crap that
you didn't have the money to pay for
pretty much okay that's not that unusual
this doesn't make you a bad person but
good it's good it's good to say it out
loud so that you don't do it again
yeah yeah
so like if this girl breaks up with you
you can't keep on this pattern and use
the the breakup as a reason to continue
to be irresponsible in your pain okay
yeah yeah I mean I did say the whole
yeah with with the new marriage thing
it's actually been a really really big
motivator yeah I started going back to
church I'd say yeah be a man that I want
to be good good that's awesome okay so
what do you make
so I'm a union uh journeyman contract or
a union journeyman uh Carpenter if I can
work full year round because sometimes
you know it's when the project comes to
an end it's kind of hard uh my but my
yearly is right around like I think like
93 000. it's not bad okay what are you
paying rent
I pay around 600
um my borough is going to be moving in
with me pretty soon
um at the place that I'm trying to get
and we're gonna be paying about 14 at
that point at 600.
okay
um all the extra information I'm giving
you I don't know I was trying to paint
the biggest picture yeah I appreciate
that yeah the um
okay uh uh
let me think here
um
I I would not tell somebody to buy a
house while they have debt I would not
tell somebody to buy a house
um and shack up with her girlfriend
especially when you just told me you're
going back to church those are
inconsistent things
um I would not tell somebody to
um uh I would tell somebody to live on
nothing and pay off this debt really
really fast making 90 by taking 16 jobs
taking every job you can get your hands
on swings a hammer makes some money
um and what what I'm what I would love
for you to do is to really clarify your
life and say I'm only going to do a
couple things here but I'm gonna do
those things really well I'm going to
engage in uh some pre-marriage
counseling I'm going to plug into this
church learn how to like you said I'm
going to be a different kind of a man
and and I'm gonna find out how to be a
wonderful world-class husband I'm going
to concentrate on that part of that
picture is I'm also going to live on
nothing and I'm gonna have to tell
Grandpa right now I can't do this deal
and I'm gonna get this dadgum mesh
cleaned up that I made so that when you
step down the altar uh you're a
different guy than you were two years
ago and it puts you in a completely
different thing that's the whole process
that's what I would tell you to do I
don't know if you're going to do any of
it but that's what I would do you need
uh you're even talking to you is chaotic
I'm gonna say you can't fix anything
unless you stop talking to yourself like
you're trash like you're the worst guy
that ever existed
um because you're just pumping that into
your brain and you gotta stop
you fell in love with somebody and you
were together for 10 years and you got
burned and it ended tough and then you
made some rash decisions joined the the
long line of us that have all done
similar things after breakups what you
have to do is decide I'm gonna I'm gonna
make this thing different I I would love
in another world to have a different
conversation because I don't know that
you're ready to get married because you
still can't even talk about your ex
without
not being able to breathe
and so I want you to make very very sure
you're you're ready to take on a
lifelong Covenant till death do you part
with this person this person could be
wonderful could have inspired you to go
back to church and fix your life and all
that but this person isn't your personal
Savior and if you if you saddle this new
girlfriend slash fiance future wife with
that it will end in Ash it's somebody to
walk alongside you and together y'all
create something new this is not
somebody that she's gonna carry you
through through the all the mess she's
making you feel better right now
um but man make sure you are all made
rock and roll before you go go get
hitched up here there's a difference
between her motivating you to a higher
level of nobility and you deciding to go
to a higher level of nobility that's the
difference in her healing you and you
healing you yeah you know and people
that you care about and love they should
motivate you to go get better they
should not and and it sounds like she's
a quality lady I agree with that
um and so uh but but yeah you need to
get aligned with hey I'm gonna get on a
track I'm gonna get with some men get
some men in my life I'm gonna get
plugged into this church uh I'm gonna
start thinking about how I'm gonna treat
this lady like I would treat like I'd
want some some character to treat my
daughter someday and I'm gonna honor
myself and treat myself that good too
yeah stop beating yourself up man
absolutely proud of you let's get it
going let's get it going absolutely this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
our scripture today Hebrews 4 12 for the
word of God is alive and active sharper
than any double-edged sword it
penetrates even
to the dividing Soul and Spirit narrow
joint joints and Marrow it judges the
thoughts and attitudes of the heart
Booker T Washington said live out of
your imagination not your history Kevin
is with us in St Louis hi Kevin welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi can you guys hear me absolutely
what's up
uh well I was just calling in it's um
I've been trying to get in for a bit
um well I my wife and I had a daughter
over a year ago just over a year ago and
uh she was born into the NICU for over
120 days and
um during that time I admitted to her
some uh stuff in our marriage that I
should have mentioned a while ago and so
it's kind of put a relationship into
basically a hoe and uh what did you tell
her that you did
well I've had two emotional Affairs in
her and the first two years of our
marriage and how long ago was that
that was in back in 2021
oh just the other day
yeah okay yeah so and then you tell her
you tell her this while the kid is in
NICU yeah I we talked to a counselor and
um
I basically
um that later that night you know I I
said I was struggling with some stuff
and she asked me hey what else were you
struggling with and I said well I
um now I had two emotional Affairs in
you
um at the beginning of our relationship
okay so where are we now bro
um so it's been a year
um so my daughter turned a year uh last
Friday and uh we're now we're working
through since we've been you know
talking to counselors throughout this
whole year and we're finally trying to
get back on track with our marriage and
I'm I'm getting back from that
relationship with God and so is she and
um we're we're trying to
I guess not get back to where we were
but become even a better couple than
before and
um we're uh currently we're in about 67
000 a debt and I'm I'm trying to figure
out how I can be a leader again in our
marriage and how I can you know walk us
through this walk us through other stuff
like our relationship with God through
um even after I've been you know a jerk
the whole time
I don't
ask the question a little more clearer
because it sounds like you've got a
pretty clear path ahead of you you did
some you you you did some stupid stuff
and you said you admitted it you said
I'm sorry and then you've been doing the
work to get it back and now you've got a
financial mess to clean up which is a
way y'all could come together
um you have a daughter who was
um on the brink and she pulled through
and I mean so it sounds like you're
unable to see the blessings and the the
light on the path that you're on and you
you're the one that keeps wanting to go
back
yeah yeah
you gotta dude you gotta quit dragging
that crap that from the past back
yeah is your wife the one bringing it up
all the time
no I think
I think that we we had just started
talking to our pastor like about a month
ago and trying to get the church to help
us out and so I think what's the church
need to help you out for
um just with our marriage you know um
what's still wrong with your marriage
I think
I think my wife
my wife has been having trouble trusting
me and I mean I haven't really been
fully committed and uh and so probably
about a month and a half ago
well then dude you've got a long way to
go sounds like you've been going through
the motions and and Performing for the
last Almost year
yeah
she deserves better than that my friend
yeah so I mean I think so she should I
thought you said you've been seeing a
counselor for a year yeah she should not
trust you she shouldn't your counselor
just inapped
I mean no I should have called you out
for not being all in
yeah I I think you're right about that
she shouldn't trust you right now and
that's fine if she's choosing to
continue to be married to you as y'all
rebuild Trust Great be trustworthy
starting today be trustworthy
yeah you owe 67 000 get four jobs by the
end of this weekend
yeah
stop sitting around and moping and just
letting stuff Loop and loop do you still
have something you haven't told her yet
no I've been uh clear about everything
with her okay then why have you been
only part way in the last nine months
um are you drag a new mother who's
trying to keep alive at night NICU baby
I mean what are you doing
I'm I guess I'm just
I'm not really sure I guess I'm just
kind of
um I guess I'm scared that like I won't
be a good leader and you're not being
one
yeah
and that can change right now
you want to be a good leader be a person
who's trustworthy be a person who shows
up and commit and does what they say
they're gonna do
be a person who puts a plan down on the
table and not doesn't just direct the
plan and but asks takes actions for the
good of others not yourself exactly how
can we co-create this thing together
what do I need to do to begin to earn
trust back because I blew it
yeah and then after I told you I was all
in I lied to you for another nine months
yeah you got a long road man and I think
it's all worth it you can do it yeah you
can do it absolutely you can there's
nothing that there's nothing you told us
that preempt you or exclude you from
being a good leader in the future
right or for being a man of fanatical
Integrity in the future from being a um
a husband who serves his wife and child
in the future which is called a man
um there's nothing that excludes you
from doing that all of these things are
choices they're not DNA
right it's not it's not imprinted on
your soul you just get to wake up in the
morning and go now I is one now I is a
man of integrity now I is a man who is
worthy of trust because I am trustworthy
now I is a person who thinks about how I
can make everybody's life around me
better
um and that's not codependence that's
service and those that are first shall
be last those that are last will be
first the greatest joy on the planet is
learning to serve
and so you hear me getting on to you man
I want you to hear me
trying to do the best I can to turn the
lights on and off to turn the music off
to put my hands on on your shoulders and
look at you and say do you got so much
Beauty around you you got so much good
around you
yeah you got to decide I'm going to be
in I'm gonna go do these things you
gotta stop thinking about everything and
stop chit chatting about everything and
stop whining about everything go get
after it Kevin there's an old story that
um I don't know if it's true or not but
Tony Robbins told it for years he said
there was two twin boys that grew up
their father was a bank robber is in
prison
and one of the young men became a a
spiritual giant highly successful in
business and the other one became a bank
robber and was in prison
the researchers went to interview them
and interviewed the young man the twin
that was in prison and they said
um you know why are you in prison he
said well the Father Like Mine who
wouldn't be
and he went and interviewed the guy who
was highly successful and had become a
spiritual giant they said how did you
become highly successful and become a
spiritual giant he said with a father
like mine why wouldn't I be
and so what it amounts to is they made
choices they both blamed it on their
father but neither one of those were
accurate they both made choices about
their future you can choose the path you
do get to choose that it's not imprinted
on you and so um you know leaders are
not born
leaders are people that just decided to
lead it's a set of skills that I'm going
to lean into I'm going to learn it like
carpentry just going to learn I'm not
gonna do it and then I'm going to do it
I'm going to do it I'm going to practice
I'm gonna do it marriage being a good
husband being a good wife is a it's a
decision and a series of skills to be
developed uh but you know I'm my wife
didn't come with a manual
um well my wife gave me one that she
wrote
but it has changed over time most of us
aren't married to a PhD but yeah yeah so
there's that but the
but yeah I so Kevin I've got great hope
for you um
because the beginning of
uh a resurrection the beginning of a
renewal in your life and you're getting
a brand new path that's a whole new path
regardless of your past is uh is is
the simple Act of repentance which means
a turning away I'm turning away from the
old man I'm gonna become a new man and
that's a decision you can do it hang on
the line I'm gonna send you a copy of on
your past change your future on me but I
want you to read it all the way through
and I want you to begin to follow that
path
that puts us out of the Ramsey Show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]